but the scale of this one in mariposa
county marks an unnerving start to the
wildfire season
on the doorstep of yosemite national
park home to some of the largest and
oldest trees in the world
the fire has ripped through a handful of
rural homes and businesses but threatens
thousands more
and remains out of control
they came by about 15 20 minutes ago and
told us that everybody's got to go about
four o'clock the power went out
and the fire has been coming towards us
faster and faster
a huge evacuation order is in place more
than six thousand people have left their
homes already as the fire traveled at
frightening speed
spitting out embers that fell as far as
two miles away
this wildfire comes as a record heat
wave is sweeping the united states with
heat warnings and emergencies declared
in several states
everything that's burning in the fire is
extremely dry we know that california
has been dry the last few years and has
gotten drier we just ask that the public
be patient if their
neighborhood or their community has been
affected by the fire it will take a
little while to notify them if they have
if their residents have been affected
climate change is driving the ferocity
of these fires the intense heat and
worse drought in decades spanning the
flames
but so far america has found no
political consensus on a way forward
that will do anything to prevent more of
this in the future
sally lockwood sky news washington